we have our first details on that Wonder
Woman sequel how you can get a part in
the next fantastic beast movie and
what's going on with the Mummy's art
universe a little boy a lot that's all
coming up on this week's ET at the
movies hey everyone I'm ash Crossan I'm
John Boone and one time in college I saw
The Mummy 3 by myself oh can we hear
that story there's really not a story I
went with a bunch of friends to a swing
night at a jazz club and couldn't get in
because I was wearing a short and had to
walk to the movie theater and see mummy
movie but we will get to the current
mummy in a minute but first let's do
some news of the week is it a week what
do we got going on well Wonder Woman
which we talked about last week loved it
thought loved it it made a hundred
million dollars over a hundred million
which breaks records I did the highest
grossing female directed movie of the
year and we're starting to get some
details about the sequel like the fact
that it's probably going to be set in
the u.s. my biggest thing is I wanted to
stay set in the past there's been talk
about maybe it'll be in the 1930s maybe
it'll be in present-day I want it to
stay in the past because I want Diana in
the 70s I want to see like disco Diana
yes getting it on
so I'm writing it you're choreographing
it yes the party Jenkins call us
yesterday we found out Teddy Jenkins
hasn't even signed on for the sequel
though which is bonkers at this point
she was I wonder if she's holding out
for that thick contract with more money
you should make that money paddy what do
you got for me well moving on do you
remember fantastic beasts and where to
find them
my favorite movie about locating
wonderful bees wonderful beasts well
they are working on the sequel this
summer they're going to start filming
but you actually can be in it if you're
between ages 13 and 18 and eligible to
work in the UK which maybe doesn't quite
defined you know like my real age is
late twenties but my the age I go out
for the road I go out for is 16 to 18 so
I think I'm good so there you go well
Pottermore which is the site for all
things JK Rowling posted the open
casting call all you need to do is
submit
color photographs and no acting
experience necessary which is kind of
common in the Harry Potter verse they
cast a lot of unknowns okay
it's probably a small part but maybe we
could get the next the next big thing if
you're the next Daniel Radcliffe submit
that color photo hey why don't we move
on to the et exclusive of the weeds we
need to get that app John Lithgow is
going to be in pitch perfect 3 and he
reveals to us exactly what his role is
and explained it like with the
enthusiasm of a newborn baby I love it
take a look pitch perfect 3 will we get
to hear you sing yes what do you think
oh my god that I won't tell you I want
everything to be a surprise but I play I
will tell you this I play rebel Wilson's
dad god I can only assume uh CH fun I
played his kind of scuzzy Australian
conman her estranged father does he
Australian conman Clooney would be
breaking John Lithgow news here on ET at
the movies hey there you go why don't we
move on to the movie of the week which
is the mummy mummy starring Tom Cruise
and a little Russell Crowe in there as
our dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde you know
your beauty monsters and you should
because this is a remake of a remake yes
it is a remake of the 1999 The Mummy
which starred Brendan Fraser which
itself is a remake of the 1930s classic
The Mummy Tom Cruise had told us that he
really wanted to go back to those days
of the classic monsters and what you got
to take a look at what he had to say
about that you know mummy series
basically Universalists
it is the movie that really put
Universal on the map back in the early
30s it was the first blockbuster for
Universal Pictures so it's more in the
classic vein of the original and the
kind of monster films that I grew up
watching it's also the first movie and
the soon to be expansive dark universe
sansa which starts with the mummy
and next is Bride of Frankenstein and
then is going to be the Wolfman the
Invisible Man The Creature from the
Black Lagoon did the mummy get you
excited
honestly no here's the photo I know I
you know I love those suspenseful slow
build kind of classic monster movies and
I was expecting that with what how it
was described and everything that Tom
Cruise said and then we got the first
trailer and it's an action-packed CG
kind of looks like the brendan fraiser
version I don't really know what's super
different about it and just see you know
an a-list star does not a good movie
make and it just seems like they are
packing it and packing and packing it
with the biggest a listers and that
doesn't draw people to the theater
anymore what did you think I actually
liked it I thought it was fun I thought
sofia boutella was great she is amazing
but mommy I'm happy she's in like a
million movies this week and I think I
wrote the nicest review about this year
that I got but I read a review today
that somebody called it the worst Tom
Cruise movie ever and I was like clearly
this is someone that's never seen Jack
Reacher yeah do you like my reaction uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but I
have some spoilery thoughts about the
future the dark universe that I'm kind
of confused about but know I once
everyone hasn't had a chance to see it
will kind of break all that downs but
for now I will say I'm excited for Bride
of Frankenstein below I am excited out
of all of them that one for sure
now ah yes I have a game for you because
I know you love game
I do love games this game is called are
you my mummy and I'm going to give you a
fact a little trivia if you will and
you're gonna have to tell me whether
it's about the star of the current mummy
Tom Cruise Tom Ford Tom Ford or the star
of the 1999 mummy Brendan Fraser okay
are you ready to play are you my mommy
yes number one
whose trademarks on IMDb are his deep
resonant voice and athletic frame Tom
Cruise's Brendan Fraser Tom Cruise's is
his boundless offstage energy well I
just figured Tom Cruise was running but
he's athletic it isn't his Twitter bio
that that was a fact that I was gonna
include but his sort of lie always like
been running in movies since 1981 anyway
number two
whose real last name is Mapother oh my
god I'm not having you with easy trib
Tom Cruise yes yes is his middle name
ding ding ding my gosh it's like a Jamie
Foxx thing all over again
number 3 who suffers from dyslexia and
said he was once quote a functional
illiterate ain't L group above yeah yeah
thinking they remember this uh number
four who also has Canadian citizenship
Brendan Fraser yep I'm saying I had him
in a while
yeah his parents are Canadian he was
born here everybody has dual citizenship
there oh five who enrolled in seminary
school when he was 14 to become a priest
but dropped out after one year hmm
sounds like Tom Cruise giving you a big
Tom Cruise
that's is it hungry yes now getting
again some curse number six
who lost favorite butt kicker at the
2012 Kids Choice Awards to Taylor
Lautner for The Twilight Saga Breaking
Dawn Part 1 oh my god Tom Cruise yeah
and that was for Mission Impossible
Ghost Rider bound by bags that is an
award that Taylor Lautner Taylor Lautner
went up on stage after winning that it
was like I beat Tom Cruise
oh I beat Meryl yeah I've URL number oh
man
number seven who almost played mr.
fantastic in the 2005 version of
Fantastic Four
that's the one with Chris Evans and
Jessica Alba well he a Brendan Fraser
kind of looks like he would be a mr.
fantastic it is you know your Brendan
Pernod I am a bit of pressure whiz who
knew number eight who is named drop
on kanye west through the wire it's
gotta be Tom Cruise wouldn't you love it
if Kanye was just name dropping Brendan
Fraser on charge yes can you freestyle
something with George of the jungle in
it right now
George George George of the jungle
Brendan Fraser is the best great you've
got over half of them you want I am
surprised that I know much more about
Brendan Fraser than I thought I would
yeah I like that you don't frame it as I
know about Tom Cruise and Brendan Fraser
you're like I know everything about
Brendan Fraser yeah I do
Georgia holic I'm the biggest Brendan
Fraser friend well well thank you for
playing I think that's probably all the
time we got for today yeah we're talking
about
rough night and car 3 next week so go
down in the comments for us tell us what
you thought about the mummy let us know
if you're excited for the dark universe
and if you want to get ahead for next
week if there's a cars to fan out there
it really exists I would love and in
defense of cars to put that down in the
comments you might hear it on next
week's show
yeah like comment subscribe all that
stuff see you next week
you
[Music]